hello my name is as perez and welcome to
rt essentials today we're talking about
one of my favorite subjects scream
queens
aka final girls or the more accurate but
less catchy influential women in the
horror genre yeah doesn't quite roll off
the tongue but as long as scary movies
have been around there have been iconic
female characters to rival that of any
monster but as the genre evolved so did
its leading ladies frequently becoming a
bigger presence than the monsters
themselves and today we are going to
celebrate these actresses who chew gum
kick butt and take names as long as
those names aren't beetlejuice or
candyman as always the spoiler alert is
in effect and now let's get to the
queens of the screen
sarah michelle gellar what's the trouble
that's him
behind him
it's weird to think of sarah michelle
gellar as a scream queen after all she's
most recognizable as buffy the vampire
slayer and buff wasn't much of a
screamer more like a kick butt and take
names here but for anyone of a certain
age the 90s were a veritable gellersons
between scream 2 the grudge i know what
you did last summer and two scooby doo's
the actress became the ascendant queen
of final slayers
only 19 years old when buffy premiered
in 1997 geller was already on her way to
being an industry pro the year prior to
filming buffy she won a daytime emmy for
her role in all my children and she'd
also been a competitive figure skater a
black belt in taekwondo and a 4.0 gpa
student meanwhile i spent my late teens
ruining my hair with drugstore hair dye
it's healthy now
hello
yet sarah michelle didn't have enough
time to literally do it all she actually
turned down jordana brewster's roles in
the faculty and the fast and the furious
and passed on starring in a movie
version of sabrina the teenage witch she
wasn't even originally up for buffy
summers instead she was brought to read
for mean girl cordelia so yeah that's
what a variant timeline looks like need
a hand
no thanks
[Music]
i'm good geller's work ethic was the
stuff of legends she was the only actor
to appear in all 145 episodes of buffy
and spent her down time on the sets of
other films she didn't even attend the
wrap party for buffy because she was too
busy filming scooby-doo
and if you thought buffy summers was
hardcore she had nothing on geller who
performed all her own stunts and worked
through a broken hand while training for
buffy the whole time i was in that house
i felt something was wrong
while filming the grudge the actress
developed an allergy to the water in
japan that was so bad the crew had to
actually tape garbage bags on her legs
while filming the iconic shower scene
[Music]
sigourney weaver
[Music]
nobody broke the final girl mold harder
than sigourney weaver did when she
stepped in ellen ripley's gigantic
xenomorph kicking space boots for ridley
scott's 1979 alien
not content to be just a living legend
in one genre weaver spent a career
crossing streams from horror to sci-fi
from the alien franchise to ghostbusters
cabin in the woods galaxy quest the
village paul and wally though for my
money her biggest horror sci-fi film
today is avatar david cronenberg-esque
body horror where humans become aliens
and use their sentient airports to plug
in directly to space dragons so gross
but before there were navi there was
just space aliens in ripley a character
who had originally been written for a
leading man gender swapping the lead
paid off for both the alien franchise
and weaver who earned her first oscar
for reprising ripley for the sequel
aliens in 1986. now this was a huge deal
as horror is still only rarely
recognized by the academy along with
[ __ ] spacek linda blair glenn close and
jody foster weaver is only one of 14
women who have ever earned an oscar
nomination for a horror movie now for my
money there are few stories as tailored
for legendary movie trivia status as
weaver's athletic prowess on the set of
alien resurrection the scene called for
the ripley clone to sink a basketball
into the hoop over her shoulder from
half court while walking in the opposite
direction plan to achieve with trick
editing
instead weaver actually sinks the basket
during her first take which was almost
ruined by co-star ron perlman's goofy
reaction witnessing the
once-in-a-lifetime dunk
something of a predator isn't she he's
vegan i don't care who he is you're not
gonna take my baby
now to nab the role of dana the love
interest in ghostbusters the stanford
and yale graduate school alum stood up
on the couch mid-audition and began
acting like a dog director ivan reitman
decided on the spot to offer her the
part
[Music]
writer dan aykroyd was considering
making the character an actress model or
alien it was weaver's idea for dana to
be a musician
[Music]
heather langen camp
[Music]
[Applause]
in 1984 heather langenkamp appeared in
nightmare on elm street as nancy the
final girl the first freddy krueger
movie it was a role she beat out 200
other women for and was chosen by wes
craven specifically for her
non-hollywood girl next door look true
to form the final audition took place on
friday the 13th of january 1984. this is
just a dream he isn't real
she took to the role of nancy so well
that craven enlisted her for two sequels
1987's nightmare on elm street part 3
dream warriors and 1994's new nightmare
a meta horror film where she starred as
a fictionalized version of herself being
terrorized by an all to irl freddy
miss me
[Music]
in fact new nightmare was based on
lankan camp's experience with an irate
stalker angered that her tv show was
cancelled guess he wasn't happy she
wasn't welcome to prime time though
langenkamp is best known to us forever
as nancy you can also find her cameoing
and horror thrillers like truth or dare
hellraiser judgment the demolitionist
and shocker she's also appeared in
american horror story freak show and
along with her husband lankin camp has
worked in makeup and special effects for
gory flicks like zack snyder's dawn of
the dead dead silence and cabin in the
woods
i'm crazy after all
lupita nyong'o
the girl had a second child a boy this
time
they had to cut her open and take her
from her belly the shadow had to do it
all
if you thought it was hard for horror
actresses to get nominated for oscars
try convincing an oscar winner that
their next role should be in a scary
movie but if you're gonna do it go the
lupita nyong'o route because by starring
in us jordan peel's 2019 follow-up film
after the critical and commercial
darling that was get out the addition of
12 years a slave star may have surprised
people but considering peel's get out
was one of only six horror films to ever
be nominated for best picture lupita's
donning of those golden garden cheers
makes more sense if you've seen us you
probably can't unsee or hear lupita's
deep raspy voice as the leader of the
tethered don't burn
a group of subterranean doppelgangers
who live in the tunnels that run
underneath the country forced to mimic
the actions of their luckier twins who
happen to be born above ground in fact
lupita based the character's voice and
[ __ ] mannerisms on robert kennedy jr
to promote the film lupita showed up on
the set of stephen colbert's late show
with yellow contacts did either of her
characters in the film have yellow eyes
no but seriously who cares i mean we
admire her full-tilt commitment to going
method weird super fun time on our trip
i want you all in the line in front of
me and the way we go
why are we stopping
there must be something in the way
are you okay
yes
but besides us lupita also starred in
the 2019 zombie flick little monsters
with josh gatt not to be confused with
the 80s fred savage howie mendel family
friendly creature feature but right on
the heels of us and black panther the
actress was instrumental in securing the
rights to taylor swift's shake it off to
the low-budget australian indie about a
kid's summer camp overrun with zombies
now after trying to reach taylor's reps
with no success director abe forsyth
shared his vision with his star who
immediately emailed taylor swift and had
the pop star agree to lend her hit to
the film
vera farmiga
[Music]
when vera farmiga signed on in 2013 to
place self-proclaimed medium lorraine
warren in james wands the conjuring
nobody knew how much she'd sign up for i
mean she's now at the helm of the second
highest grossing horror franchise of all
time with an extended universe to rival
that of the avengers now 8 films with a
combined budget of 125 million eat your
heart out james blom the conjuring films
which includes the nun the curse of la
llorona and all the annabelle movies was
a minor public relations miracle the
ghost hunting duo was infamous for
courting tabloids but in the hands of
farmiga and co-star patrick wilson they
are the catholic church equivalent of
the avengers by the power of god
i condemn you back to hell
in particular took her role very
seriously traveling to the warren's
house to speak to lorraine so she could
and i quote absorb her essence gross
[Music]
you liked it
nonetheless the orphan and bates motel
star is the biggest subscriber to the
warren lore i mean farmiga frequently
talks about how filming the conjuring
has led to some pretty spooky real-life
incidents she's been haunted by the
appearance of mysterious claw marks
everywhere from her computer screen to
her skin to
toilet paper i mean weird place for
ghosts to make themselves known but when
you gotta go you gotta go i guess and in
case you're wondering no the character
of lorraine warren isn't supposed to be
related to the character of sister irene
in the spin-off the nun but the two have
more in common than just valic a demonic
entity taking the form of mother
superior sister irene is played by none
other than tysa farmiga vera's younger
sister by 21 years in total there are
seven farmiga siblings which by the
conjuring logic makes them prime
potential possesses
lynn shay
horror is a young person's game i mean
you've got to be pretty limber to outrun
a slasher or survive being thrown out a
window you know what i mean but it's
also a genre where the rules were made
to be broken enter linshay now you may
have seen lynn in any one of her 140
plus credits over the past 40 years in
roles like teacher from nightmare on elm
your mother street nurse from new
nightmare time for your medicine cowboy
or magda and there's something about
mary remember magda
shea's most recognizable role though for
modern audiences is elise raynor a
psychic medium who helps the lambert
family from james juan and lee wennell's
insidious franchise now rayner is
actually the only actor to return for
all three sequels taking an increasingly
central role in the series despite and
spoilers here the character was actually
killed off at the end of the first film
don't ask me how it works folks i am
just stating the facts so even without
insidious shae's got an impressive
resume of 27 horror movies backing up
her claim of grand dame of the scream
queens 2001 maniacs critters amityville
new generation the running man ouija and
the grudge just to name a few in 2015
she was given the title godmother of
horror at wizard world comic con though
it may be unsurprising because shea is
horror royalty her brother is new line
cinema founder bob shay so one of her
earliest roles was in nightmare on elm
street as nancy's teacher as she told
entertainment weekly bob's exact quote
to wes craven as a condition to new line
financing the film was put my sister in
the movie
a demon
who seeks dalton's body for one reason
to cause pain to others
sarah paulson
[Music]
in 2011 ryan murphy cast broadway
actress sarah paulson in a small role as
psychic billy dean howard in his debut
season of american horror story she's
played a total of 13 characters across
eight titles of the anthology series
paulson has quickly become one of the
most prolific actresses in hollywood and
despite 2020's dearth of new content she
starred in the hulu acquired horror
thriller run playing the overbearing
mother of a teenager i'm your mom
it's my job to take care of you when you
need me
and she also headlined murphy's ratchet
what are you gonna do about it
what are you death no
just thinking of all the things i'm
going to do about it the limited series
on netflix based very loosely on the
antagonists from kenkeezy's one flew
over the cuckoo's nest although she's a
frequent collaborator with murphy who
originally hired her for a small role on
niptuck paulsen's big break actually
came from another horror legend so in
1996 she played the older sister to
lucas black in american gothic a
short-lived cbs horror series cancelled
after only one season the forgotten
series paved the way for paulson's
ascendancy to tv's reigning scream queen
paulson also started getting cred behind
the scenes directing an episode of the
seemingly prescient season american
horror story apocalypse which must be
how murphy retained his leading lady
after she was named one of time
magazine's most influential people in
the world it's all coming true but none
of it is possible with you here i beg of
you come backwards for me
i was having the most beautiful dream
for me it was a nightmare
betty gabriel
you didn't even need to have seen jordan
peele's first movie to be shook by betty
gabriel's performance as georgina the
black maid of the armitages and get out
the trailers for the film framed her an
alarming close-up repeating oh no into
the camera with a glazed smile and a
single tear falling down her face
no no no no no no no no no no
i'm pretty sure there are people who
haven't even seen get out who have
nightmares thanks to gabriel's hypnotic
and terrifying performance and that's
got to be a world record i mean two
words and we're scared for life even
frankenstein's monster said a few more
than that and even though she was only
in a few scenes of the film gabriel was
on her way to becoming a horror icon so
in 2016 a year before she would
officially get out the actress got
involved with influential hollywood
horror disruptor blumhouse productions
when she starred in purge election year
playing a reformed murder marauder and
officially solidifying herself as a
staple in the pantheon of scary movies
that doubled as social commentary
purge marked just the first of six
collaborations between gabriel and jason
blum that year she co-starred in
blumhouse horror miniseries 12 angry
days before nabbing the role of georgina
and one year later she pulled double
duty in unfriended dark web as a woman
whose friend group is being stalked by
cyber criminals and as a detective who
suspects logan marshall green of
murdering the bionically enhanced thugs
who killed his wife in lee wennell's
directorial debut upgrade
now if gabriel looks familiar but you
haven't seen any of these films which by
the way you totally should just ask
yourself did you sign up for cbs all
access at any point in 2019 and happen
to catch a particularly meta episode of
jordan peele's new twilight zone so
gabriel cameoed as herself alongside
seth rogen in the season finale blurry
man
seriously what's going on
bay duna
south korean actress bei duna who
actually got her start in 1999's the
ring virus a korean remake of the
original japanese film got her big break
when she teamed up with director park
chan woke in 2002 for his ultra-violent
sympathy for mr vengeance the first
installment of his vengeance trilogy
which would go on to include old boy and
lady vengeance just uh lots of vengeance
with that guy duna played the daughter
of an electronics factory worker who is
kidnapped by a deaf mute employee
desperate to raise money for his
sister's kidney surgery things do not go
as planned the hyper gruesome violence
of the story freaked duna out so park
would have her eat food during her early
scene but duna got over her
squeamishness next working with bong
joon ho in 2006 for his creature feature
the host
now unfortunately for the actress the
movie involved a 40-foot tall monster
lizard called guamul that abducts duna's
character and carts her off from her
family ending in a climactic battle as
she dangled from its tail above a bridge
we say unfortunately since juna suffers
from acrophobia also known as a fear of
heights now the host was in immediate
smash making box office history as the
highest grossing south korean film of
all time buna had her pick of projects
but continued working in the realm of
sci-fi fantasy and horror you can find
her in the wachowski's cloud atlas
playing at least four characters and
incense eight which the matrix siblings
produced also on netflix you can find
her in a show called the kingdom a south
korean political horror thriller which
honestly is a genre i didn't know i
needed in my life until now
tony collette what is scary
[Music]
[Applause]
at what point did tony collette become
the face of horror was it back in 1999
when she played hayley joel osment's mom
in the sixth sense and earned herself
one of those coveted oscar nominations
in the genre
or was it in 2018 when she starred in
hereditary a film so disturbing that it
turned its distributor into a name
synonymous with art house terror now
here's the thing in a filmography that
spans 80 rolls in two decades colette's
only been in a total of five horror
movies the sixth sense 2011's fright
night krampus hereditary and velvet
buzzsaw
in fact colette's made it very clear
that she's actually not a fan of the
genre saying in multiple interviews that
she's too petrified to watch her own
films so how does a scaredy cat end up
in two of the most influential horror
movies of their decades talk it up to
her poor reading habits now listen to
this having only read the script scene
that she planned to audition with
collette almost passed on the sixth
sense because she didn't want to do a
formulaic hollywood action movie she
only found out she'd been in a horror
film after its release she'd been so
focused on hitting the emotional beats
in her scenes that she actually missed
the part where her son was seeing dead
people
lol from then on colette made sure to
read the scripts more closely of course
and thankfully it paid off in one of the
most acclaimed performances of her
career as annie graham the matriarch of
a family haunted by metaphorical and
then quite literal demons in arya's
hereditary just say it just
don't you swear at me don't you ever
raise your voice at me i am your mother
do you understand it was a role she'd
originally been reluctant to take but
reading the script she realized it was
more a complex exploration of the nature
of grief and loss than it was about kill
counts and jump scares hereditary became
a24's biggest box office earner to date
and love it or hate it and she probably
hates it colette will now forever be
associated as the indie horrors biggest
mom
louie
are you okay
are you in pain
nev campbell
showtime then why don't you show your
face you
coward
my pleasure
[Music]
in 1996 a little movie came out by the
name of scream and forever changed how
we think about horror movies bucking the
archetypes of teens and scary movies the
characters in wes craven and kevin
williamson's meta slasher were smart
self-referential and very much aware of
the rules of the genre do you want to
die sydney
your mother sure didn't
star nev campbell became the face of the
franchise as sydney prescott a
cool-headed brunette with nerves of
steel and a knack for attracting
stalkers who love murder and movie
trivia in equal amounts but long before
she was old enough to find out if she
likes scary movies the canadian actress
starred in an episode of are you afraid
of the dark
dude
a scary story anthology show for kids
that aired on nickelodeon's original
saturday night snick lineup that may or
may not have been the theme of my 14th
birthday now her first movie role was
also in a horror film called the dark
which my sources are telling me was
about a giant rat and i don't want to
know anything more
what the
what's that thing now if you were around
for the 90s and it's crazy that some of
you weren't you might remember campbell
from her role in the craft after
director andrew fleming apparently
thought yeah she could play a catholic
school girl peer pressured into joining
a super goth coven it was originally
drew barrymore who was cast as sydney
and scream but due to schedule conflicts
had to make the smaller role of casey
becker nev was originally hesitant to
take on another big horror film i'm
sensing a trend here but accepted it for
the opportunity to have a starring role
and work with legendary filmmaker wes
craven nev didn't want to come back for
a fifth screen movie without craven who
died in 2015 but she was swayed by a
handwritten note from the film's
directors matt bettinelli open and tyler
gillette in which they admitted that
they had become filmmakers after being
inspired by the work of her and craven
in scream
give mommy a kiss and we'll make up
jamie lee curtis
i mean what can you say about jamie lee
curtis aka lori strode the bane of
michael meyer's existence in the
halloween franchise her feature film
debut was in fact john carpenter's 1978
iconic slasher film which has spanned
over 40 years 11 movies not including
the two upcoming installments from
director david gordon green and
countless comics novels video games and
hollywood horror night appearances
carpenter's decision to cast an unknown
to star in his film might have struck
some people as strange but it was
actually a tribute to alfred hitchcock
one of carpenter's biggest idols janet
lee who starred in hitchcock's psycho is
curtis's mother in fact jaime might have
made her first film away earlier in life
when she was in talks to appear in
psycho 2. it never materialized curtis
would get the chance to share the screen
with her mother first in 1980 with john
carpenter's fog and again in halloween
h2o
oh damn it oh
oh mistake i'm so sorry i i didn't mean
to make you jump now it's nice when
parents can share a bonding experience
with their kids like running away from
serial killers or murderous mist after
halloween curtis became the reigning
scream queen of the 1980s her next big
film prom night couldn't even get
financed until she signed on for it
though curtis left the halloween
franchise after halloween 2 she
expressed interest in h2o after had
already been bought by the studio so
writer kevin williamson was brought in
to re-haul the story to center on lori
strode and her college age son
though she had no plans to return to the
franchise the third time she was
convinced by her godson jake gyllenhaal
to take a meeting with director david
gordon green and the rest as they say is
horror movie history
you want your mask
come and get it
i'm coming for you michael well friends
that is it for our list of essential
women in horror if you want to check out
more scary movies or just like your
movie news in listicle form keep it here
on rt essentials my name is nas perez
and i am here to tell you to keep it
spooky
[Music]
you